going back to the beginning when you
first had a twinkle in your eye thinking
about filmmaking however long ago that
was what questions would you have wanted
to ask a tiff alum a Sundance alum
someone who has distribution wow I have
to I'm really going back in time my
imagination now I didn't know anything
when I started making movies I was in
high school I was running around with a
VHS camcorder in the woods of my friends
we were emulating friday the 13th and we
didn't even know why I think we were
just it was fun it was just a thing that
we would do I don't think I had
professional aspirations until I was in
my mid-20s yeah Sam yeah while I didn't
know what producers did I had no idea
what producers it I don't know what any
of the roles really were I said cuz you
only ever hear about the director you
know hear about all of the other people
that are like around that are also doing
a lot of creative things department
heads what each department does a lot of
the technical stuff i think is always a
barrier for entry for people i think i
would have in the very beginning had
some really foolish questions like how
do i get good cameras yeah and yeah you
know or how do i get my film out there
which you hear a lot but uh how do i get
somebody other than I like mom to
finance my name yeah but I think down
the I think down the road a little bit
it would have been more I think I've
been more about process it just would
have been you know what how is that
scary how did you make that scary you
know where do you where do the ideas
come from how do you follow through upon
them you know
I think I don't know I think for me it
was it wasn't till I went to Sundance
that I started meeting professional
filmmakers and they kind of blew my mind
so how do you compose a scene I think
that would be one that I would ask like
shot listing that kind of thing that was
something I didn't even you don't even
think about when you watch a film or
even when you're first getting into
making them you just think like oh yeah
that makes sense though all of this cut
together but you don't think about like
what you actually have to do and how
that means like oh you have to turn the
room around or you know how long that
process takes and what all the moving
pieces are and when they happen going
back same time going after we're running
around the woods with the camera
whatever any questions you would have
asked yourself about were you two are
now I know that seems really like out
there and weird but does that make sense
you mean if if you could look forward
into the future and talk to yourself
right would you have asked yourself
about this time that you're in right now
with which is happiness that cinefamily
the TIFF getting distribution having
several projects completed under your
belt I honestly think I would have been
kind of amazed that this is still going
oh yeah I always thought any day now
yeah this is all gonna fall apart and
the costs will outweigh the benefits and
you'll go get a real job mm-hmm that
still could happen any moment now yeah
um what could happen today yeah I not to
evade your question but just to say I
would I really like to fantasize about
it's like going back in time and talking
to myself you know having having me now
having been through all this going back
and shaking myself as a young person and
giving them all kinds of advice that you
know I wouldn't have been able to
process yeah anything you want to share
ah make everything all the time yep it's
like that thing that people say like the
secret to writing is writing you know
just the more that you make the more
experience you have in it the more
you're just practicing it's like you
have to practice it just like anything
else the more times you can get on a set
it doesn't matter in what capacity I
would go PA on any one set right now
just to the more the more that you're on
this on a set the more you learn so if
anyone needs a PA really what I'm saying
what's your contact info yeah well you
actually were anticipating maybe my next
question because how much confidence
versus uncertainty do you both have
about filmmaking even at a point where
you are now because we know that this is
a town that there's a lot of starts a
lot of stops there's a lot of ebbs and
flows and again it seems like a lot of
it comes down to just to continue
whether it's being a PA or whether it's
writing whatever but how confident do
you feel versus uncertainty about
filmmaking your career continuing I know
it's a weird question no it's it's funny
because it's like there's I feel like
that's changes from moment to moment you
know of like this is the greatest thing
we've ever done everyone's gonna love it
it's hilarious and then five seconds
later being like what are we doing why
did we do this no one's going to like
that no one's going to get it no its you
know so it's like you go back and forth
but I think in the actual process though
like the making the decisions is the
easy part and then it's like are people
going to get it is it kind of always the
question and that's like the best thing
when you're seeing an audience and
people actually like get the tone that
you're going for and they laugh at the
parts that you think are funny and
you're like oh I'm not the only one
who's like that kind of weirdo and
that's I mean one of the main benefits
to of doing test screenings I think is
that you see like oh that's not working
but it should so what do I have to do to
change
to make it work I I don't know what I'm
doing but I don't think anybody else
does either so that's it's it's a had
this theatre director that used to say
this thing you just said creatively it's
like the moment you know exactly what
you're doing is the moment you're not
doing it anymore so that it in I think
his whole point was just kind of the
feeling that you get when you get into a
creative endeavor and you're going this
is outside my comfort zone this is not
something it's not emulating something
I've done before it's taking some kind
of risks whether they be totally or
structurally it's just doing something
crazy that if you if you feel some fear
about that if you feel like you're on
less travel ground then that's you
should embrace that you should follow
that professionally I don't think
there's any certainty and I kind of feel
like I'm learning that you just have to
chalk that up to Hollywood and making
movies and what I mean yes no there's no
guarantee that any of this is going to
turn out well or that you're going to
get to do it again so like every movies
your last movie yeah the duplass
brothers had this amazing keynote that
they did at South by last year that was
the Calvary isn't coming which they
think is like the greatest title to
anything yeah where they basically talk
about that you have to keep doing things
those things on your own there's never a
moment where you like oh I've done it
now we're here bring us your monies and
your your stars and let's get going like
that never happens you're always
starting at square one like every time
you're starting over it's always putting
all the pieces together all over again I
think that's definitely a big lesson to
learn is that there isn't there wasn't
that moment where like everything starts
to get handed to you where it gets
easier like it's always going to be the
process and in a harder process every
time because you're usually if you're
creatively fulfilled with what you're
doing you're trying to do bigger things
like you're talking about that aren't in
your comfort zone so it's always going
to be that same struggle because once
that's gone I feel like yeah you're just
repeating the stuff you've already done
and then it's
it's not as interesting to you and
that'll come across I think I mean it's
always great to do like new things every
time that you're they're out there
trying to make a film so it's almost
like a manic ride but in some sense it
sounds like it should be because if it
gets too smooth into like oh okay I
think I got this then it's not really
there's no passion or you're not alive
behind it I think yeah grace the mania
good you know we've joked before that I
mean you almost have to be willing to
crash the ship into the side of a
mountain or somewhere into the rocks the
metaphor in the water I you have to be
willing to go down in flames in a very
public way like that's always kind of on
the table everyone you've ever known is
going to see this thing completely fall
apart and be a miserable failure that's
that's possibility there is a moment
that we found out that we got into
Toronto where it's like it was literally
like three seconds of elation of being
like oh this is amazing like everyone's
gonna see it it's so great and then like
the fourth second was everyone's gonna
see it oh god cuz it's like at that
point we were like batting a thousand
it's like well we liked it and our
friends liked it and Colin liked it so
we should stop now because right now
everyone likes it you know everyone gets
it at this point if we go beyond this
circle then it's open to the public
criticism and like I mean some people
get it some people do some people they
have the same similar taste sometimes
they won't but yeah it's it's funny how
that roller coaster goes where it's like
yes oh you know think especially I
think in an independent space yeah
because you you want to do something
kind of
kind of off kilter watch me more in that
space too because you don't really like
this lower budget level that we kind of
work in right now like you don't have as
much oversight and it's kind of like oh
well as long as you bring a movie back
at the end of the day it has like a
beginning middle and end or semblance of
like you they kind of let you have free
reign and I feel like once you get it to
a larger budget level there's a lot more
oversight and cooks in the kitchen so
you have kind of more it's more Wild
West I kind of think on the independent
side although I mean our projects always
have like 17 cooks in the kitchen so but
luckily we're all kind of like
creatively aligned which is more
exciting the honeymoon phase of starting
a new project or the elation of they
liked it at the end when the credits
roll I'd say it's a beginning it's the
first like coming up with the idea and
when you first start to get into who the
characters are and figuring that out and
we're pieces just start to fit together
it's like when you make all the lines in
Tetris it's like taking like straight
back to Game Boy you could though
there's nothing you're like yes it's
yeah I feel like that's like production
I mean you're not really having fun in
production but like it's it's it's such
an exciting presence you know then yeah
like quickly with this project it's like
I think for me the best moments are when
we're on the middle of a desert with the
crew and you know we're floating a light
balloon up over the desert and staging a
car accident or you know any number of
the things that we did it's extremely
exciting and
use a great sense of camaraderie with
the crew love working with crews out in
those environments I I feel like I'm
feel like we I think we're always just
trying to get back to that yeah i think
the the festival's and sending the stuff
out and seeing what people think is
least for me more more complex yeah flex
experience is usually by that point it's
like you've shot like eight or nine
months prior so you're just like when's
the next time I'm going to go back to
that when when can we get to make that
next thing so it's kind of like when
you're at that festival you're at the
furthest point away from being in
production so it's kind of both like a
low and a high it's like this is great
that everybody loves this but we're done
with this now what yeah was there a
writers room type environment with all
of you coming up with their different
parts were you really in like almost
like a television writers room where you
were together doing this or did you take
stuff home back to wherever you felt
most comfortable writing and then bring
it to like a group meeting how did that
all work for people live a little bit of
both and it's kind of coming up with the
entire concept overall and figuring out
what the mythology meant and what the
world was and then coming up with the
individual stories within that world on
our own and bringing them back to the
group and figuring out where they pieced
together and fit into that world we
definitely all went off and wrote our
own scripts at a certain point you know
and kind of came back the group and then
those would change and evolve when we
saw how they all fit together but yeah I
think we always kept the scope of the
whole thing in mind so it was it was fun
to write and know that you had a
responsibility for a certain portion of
the movie mm-hmm you know what is what
does act one feel like yeah what is what
is the end of the movie need to be you
know where are we at the 50 minute mark
kind of thing and how did you handle the
feedback with one another so was there
like okay this is an open forum and I
don't like this part I like this part
how how does that work mostly by rock
paper scissors I think that's one of the
benefits of working with a group of
people that you've worked with before
and that you have similar creative
tastes and you've talked about like
hashed out your ideas on movies together
before either your own or other peoples
is that there is a shorthand and there
is like a cutting to the chase of like
there's no kid gloves in a way not that
anyone's like overly harsh on anyone
else's stuff but it's very constructive
criticism and how do we make this
together better as a whole I don't think
there's often a moment where there's
like a a real creative standstill like I
know there weren't really were there
weren't any like serious crossroads Rosa
5050 everybody has to draw straws or
something but like yeah normally I think
there is something that emerges some
kind of wisdom of the group as several
people are around that you you know you
can bring up you know an issue that you
see in one of the other films and
present it and if it doesn't really gain
traction with everybody else then the
concern kind of floats away you know but
typically we'll all kind of having the
conversation so like if you say I don't
worried about that like I think we're
going to lose momentum here that's not
going to make any sense and we'll all
talk about it and we sort of end up in a
place and usually that can influence the
independent individual filmmaker or
maybe they have something that they're
fighting for that they haven't fully
articulated yet but it definitely things
emerge when you come together and like
pressure test these ideas mmm
that was definitely one of the coolest
parts is when I first brought the
finished first edits to watch down with
everyone before we strung them all
together and it was like the first time
that everyone was seeing like the edited
together versions because I was like oh
we made a movie we got a movie in here
somewhere and then from there it's just
whittling down and you know making finer
and finer cuts and notes on those but
there wasn't ever like oh no we're in
trouble moment on any section of either
prep or production or getting into the
editing process and sound mixing sound
design so that was kind of really cool I
don't know if that's the same for other
other people working with like that many
creative collaborators but at least for
us we I think we have enough similar
tastes and had a really good idea going
in what it was we wanted to make that
we're pretty close to that at the end
from where we started sounds like the
secret then is maybe make sure
everybody's on the same page when you
start or just maybe knowing everybody's
temperament and just knowing you never I
think if you if you if you hang around
and talk movies with other filmmakers
long enough you pretty well I don't
think takes that long you start to see
who you kind of gravitate towards or who
you can have a conversation with or
who's kind of on your wavelength so
hopefully by the time we're in that room
together at least the way this came
together you know we we kind of already
know can't already have a reporter yeah
yeah we have a pretty good idea of what
Tyler's going to say you know we know
chad is going to bring up the incredible
day thread the damaging to the movie I'd
really wanted to make a short that
wasn't horror that was all about a guy
who just has a really incredible day
it's just like wanders through all of
the horrible things and it's all just
great for him and you're just waiting
for the other shoe to fall and ever does
it's just there's zero confidence
person's life and um yeah yeah he talked
about that a lot yeah you know yeah you
get to know everybody really
and then Susan wanted to call the movie
Purgatory's mm-hmm the other one and
then and then Pat has this amazing
ability to he can eat like a whole box
of Altoids in a single creative meeting
like he's just popping yeah I'll towards
the entire time if you guys interview
him he'll probably have the altoids just
to burn on him somewhere yeah yeah so
he's it's if you need you know it's good
to sit next to Pat because he smells
amazing